okay English time English time are we
going to have no we're not just gonna
say are we gonna have a symphony of
Placid beauty who knows what I'm talking
about
we're not there we're not it's not
happening it's established upon in the
Sun all right and well where we have
this is Catalan land Queen c2 we've been
here actually I don't know how many
times you've been here and just for the
moment
one one of the videos that I posted to
my channel that I'm recalling is Kramnik
versus Carlson with this line and
kramnik was white and did what Kramnik
does best and that is squeeze the life
out of his opponent let's try this let's
try it it's an awkward move i forget who
the first one was that play did the kid
starts with the j anybody know any how
one of the meanings is to just swing it
all the way back additional support to
this in case it comes under fire what
else i might want to consider a pawn
push and i might not want to consider
that let's see let's get my night out
this right here if you're not the big
battle right here is focused on c5 and
if you're not realizing that you need to
get in that to frame of mind right now
because for as long as this guy's around
he's forever a liability what I want
what black wants to do in this position
is exchange off the C pawn for this
healthy white deep on not always the
easiest thing to do
now I was saying earlier I wanted to
play my bishop maybe all the way back to
a8 but I'm not going to do that because
another thing that I want to have with
this rook bumping up is queen AE
available I don't know how accurate
these moves are on my end but I do have
some experience with this line primarily
in blitz but yeah Queen a8 just kind of
make this night think twice about where
it position positions itself I don't
know if I really need to throw a
question this guy I'm really liking
Queen a 8 right now followed by rook c8
hmm well if you like it do it I'm not
really concerned sometimes this would
have a great a lot of my concern this
Knight a5 move oftentimes it's very in a
great inconvenience to my light-square
bishop but I think that just playing to
one of these two squares and as a
response to it is quite all right I'm
very close well if the knight does
decide to play here it's kits not going
there so now I could take and well this
pawn is no longer as much a liability
and I don't know that I could really
tolerate this guy
I think this Knight has to go where
should I hold off I might want to hold
off no I might no one still let me just
play here and now I think right here one
of these - one of these - I think right
here
yes right here it's a good spot isn't it
c6 ribbed e7r up d8 I have to be very
cautious of a night move to e5 maybe at
some point times are roughly equal okay
now wait a second let's go here now I
mean these guys are already trained on
this file in this my opponent with that
last move gave me something to bite out
so I could take here we could have a
bunch of exchanges this Bishop not the
most excited piece in the world
let's talk question this bishop about
that one no I have something for it I
think my opponent listening okay I think
Bishop f4 to pinpoint maybe c7 is a good
idea okay I was actually a little bit
scared of age six and there was a hint I
don't know if he picked up it with my
voice there I was hoping maybe Bishop
takes pawn what stock I was also hoping
my opponent was listening to the stream
just for that one move and they would
maybe take the power of power of
suggestion bait maybe and you know um
take here and then rook here what's
wrong with that
well pawn here then this night can move
a bit more freely to this square I don't
know if I want to allow that could I
really do something at a snail's paetynn
now I I gotta go faster
I gotta go faster quit thinkin move
faster take me I take you in my rook is
ready to oh I can't recapture with my
queen yes I could I think one of us it
could turn out that my opponent has a
past C pawn and I have a past beep on
rook takes Queen takes this pawn Falls
this pawn Falls maybe there's some way
as soon as this Knight moves I could
take the bishop and as soon as the king
is on this diagonal in an open position
I think that's going to favour me put
possibilities for a timely Queen check
along this diagonal and maybe forking
some piece so I'm gonna try well I might
as I might as well take with my queen
yeah I'll take with my queen oh that
move okay scary time oh man man I should
probably do this
man rook here the Bishop's gonna grab
that pond isn't it I think I got to try
this I think this is a bad choice by me
um less than a minute
I gotta go here look at this sad pond oh
man there what a disaster okay you know
what time it is
oh this was so bad I should I had to go
here this was a good move this was good
my opponents these were good moves
these are definitely good moves no can I
get away with this wealth I gotta do
this I have to do something I gotta put
pressure on this guy this nights gonna
kill me he's gonna kill me less than 50
my opponent really has me on the ropes
this this pond is this pond is ah he's
stupid he's a stupid pond on c6 don't
look at me stupid
man I got to stop that night from I'm
just gonna try this I'm in trouble
I'm losing I'm definitely in trouble and
trouble land coming up I have to sack my
knight I definitely have to sack my
knight I gotta get I gotta just allow
that I got that if I move my knight I
end up getting killed I gotta try this
and babysit this pond and hopefully this
pond can run and this pond isn't gonna
be targeted oh it's gonna be targeted
no no say it isn't so run pond you know
you're fast in your past hang on for
karu skis 28 seconds this can't be good
for me no no way Oh an unexpected move
right there I think my opponents going
astray this is a past pond however I'm
boxing out that night 19 seconds is my
opponent scared I'm scared I hope
they're scared I hope they're scared cuz
I'm scared yeah I was just gonna go here
let's go there I'll be brilliant over
here time situation where you went I got
a piece I got a piece time pressure
I was just ready to blunder blunder City
over no stay off light squares shame on
you oh no here we go I think no no oh
that was a bad pre-move Forks no not
Forks
not yet at a pre move time
that was a bad pre-move house a bad
pre-move frame of time what is it um
it's not even a war zone and I'm holding
my breath I'm sorry if you didn't know
by now you should not never ever listen
with headphones
man good game man good game lucid chest
lucid chess you played a fantastic game
man that was a really good game ah man I
was way on the ropes oh where did I go
wrong did you go wrong first I felt like
I definitely felt like I definitely felt
like I went wrong first man okay so this
is Catalan land so far so book I think I
have it right that this is a line out of
the cattle and to be honest I think
another line is to just swing that
Bishop out all the way back again
something you'd see in like a top level
game just basically saying you know what
if you want to do repetition black is
you know at that point at that level
quite alright with going for a draw so
white is the side that ends up having to
come up with something else
but for some reason from what I'm
recalling I think look there is also a
move could be I could be off with that I
really felt comfortable here okay and
the knight move wasn't really going to
bother me I didn't think if the knight
if Knight a5 was played I was gonna go
to one of these two and then I think by
force I'm able to get in this c5 advance
so maybe knight Knight there's just
would just be going astray but Knight c5
this is an interesting structure and
what a pain what a giant pain this this
poem is white sheep on turned out to be
oh man
is there something better I pretty much
have to take that night do I not I'm
really coming back to this point I'm
sort well I'm sort of fast-forwarding to
this point because it's a structural
it's the last structural change and do I
really stand well to have a white pawn
on c5 I don't know I felt like it was
quite all right Bishop and I think
something's off with B floor but it
turns out to not really be so bad
maybe h6 is wrong if I mean maybe I
should be playing here this bishop as
soon as it puts pressure on this pun I
have to do something about it I don't
really want to be tied down to the
defense of it maybe I maybe I'm just
chasing the bishop away to a square
there where it's just going to be better
placed I don't really know I don't know
I really don't know h6 is what's up what
would be another one of my candidate
moves if I'm to play this again instead
of h6 what what else might I be doing
here Bishop f4 or instead of h6 takes
maybe I should just immediately take
that's what I ended up doing h6 and then
I take why not just take right away is
this really that much of an annoying
piece I don't think so actually another
thing with h6 is that I do allow for
maybe potential sacrifices and maybe
those are two good reasons to just again
not run forward now with h6 so I think
if I could do it over again I would take
on b4 right now and then follow up with
the rook a form of like I did
yeah I think maybe that's a slight
improvement on my end and now it's now
it's a pain
I like the queen bee to move a real lot
a real lie when I was doing the quick
calculations on this I was just thinking
okay you take my pond I take yours
we each have a past pond and we try to
get each one going but you said no I
will first hang on to my B pond and I
will look to kill the Queen or just get
really an active rook and that's that's
what ends up happening here so what do I
do
there's there's a threat on this pond
threat if maybe rook here Brook activity
now white is just better white is
probably winning this yeah this has to
be winning for white rook activity is
good the night their bishop here is good
boxing out my knight I'm dead at this
point
efore is the move to go with and if I
play here my bishops dead and my rook my
knight is in trouble I think
however if Knight he'd know I mean I
okay maybe I could save a piece at this
point I'm just seeing if there's a way I
could save a piece but it's still just
bad in every variation 9075 I guess
there's knight c8 and then the bishop
could maybe go here 97 'if I've night c8
rook c7 I react with the bishop my c6
pawn files and this guy's a monster he
continues to be a monster this white C
pawn oh man good game I'm down a piece
at this point I like this move man
played a good game
you got your going right after that weak
point you got that pawn and now where is
the better well okay you don't you
shouldn't grab that pun what is what is
what's the way to finish black off here
what do you do
what's the winning method how about how
about trade rooks
right here just trade rooks and then get
going to pac-man mode on this pawn you
just trade
I can't Huck I can't get this pawn so
easily rook takes Bishop takes the
bishop posts up here but I only have a
pawn for the minor piece and that's so
not enough so maybe that's a better way
I do get the looking to my versus to
minor pieces this should still be better
for white but we're both pretty moving
like crazy
you dropped a piece but it didn't really
matter it came down to a silly little
mouse race at the end very good game oh
man okay